you were a useful distraction but i have
gods to kill
the ring to laconia is now closed
you're on your own
hoy dang about to load up
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about the expanse character winston
duarte duarte played a large role in the
free navy conflict and now that season
six has come to a close i've had a lot
of questions about his motivations and
his plans for laconia you probably know
that there are three more novels in the
expanse series that happen after the
events of season six and i will be
drawing on some things that become
apparent about the character as the
story goes on but i won't be explaining
how his story ends in this video so for
your spoiler warning i'll be focusing on
what was in the show and in the first
six books plus the novellas strange dogs
and the vital abyss with light big
picture spoilers for the final trilogy
and with that out of the way let's get
into it winston duarte makes his first
appearance in the fifth expanse novel
nemesis games alex is back on mars
before the rocks hit earth and he's
helping bobby look into some missing
martian ships he goes looking for
answers utilizing his connections from
his time in the navy and he ends up in
this guy duarte's office he is a
commander working as an aide to an
admiral and this mostly serves to
introduce the character who seems
insignificant at the time but turns out
to be important much later
he is working behind the scenes to put
together the breakaway fleet while also
providing ships to the free navy but he
doesn't play an active role in the rest
of the book in the show alex meets
sobiter instead as a way to introduce
that character so you know who he is
when he disappears while transiting the
ring at the end of the season it makes
sense because you don't have to cast
someone to play one scene as duarte in
the show and in the book soviter just
shows up in the epilogue to give you
some details about what they're doing as
the bar keith gets eaten by the ring
they do tease duarte in bobby's
storyline at the end of season 4 we see
his name on her hand terminal and in
season 5 she knows someone's above
sovietaire but he isn't revealed as the
leader of this movement until the very
end in the season 5 finale soviter
congratulates marco on his behalf for
taking control of the ring space in
medina station he refers to him as
admiral duarte which is a rank he never
achieved in the mcrn i don't think it's
a spoiler to say that duarte is a bad
guy and what i think makes him
compelling in that role is the
conditions that existed to allow him to
set his plans in motion in season 6
episode 4 when he's talking to kara he
says he lost the place and tells her he
needs it to be a sacrifice so that the
dream of mars still matters this dream
is at the heart of the laconia story and
a brief look at the history of mars
highlights why mars started out as a
colony a place where earthers who were
unhappy on the planet could look to for
the chance at a brighter future as the
population increased there weren't
enough jobs for everyone on earth and
half of its citizens survive through
what's called basic assistance this is
only for sustenance and shouldn't be
confused with a universal basic income
people on basic can't work it's
extremely hard to get off of it they
can't have children in most cases and
because their basic needs are taken care
of they have no actual money think
disposable paper clothing and rice with
textured protein instead of a monthly
check this can be a little confusing
because you often hear martians or
belters refer to earthers as lazy takers
who are content with a life of leisure
where everything is handed to them and
the reality of being on basic is a lot
more complicated than that in the early
days of mars on the other hand there was
a lot of work that needed to be done to
make it a habitable place work with
purpose something people could get
behind to feel like they were making a
difference the generations long project
to terraform the planet is what defined
the society and this commitment to a
shared goal is what set them apart from
those lucky earthers who have it so easy
back on the home world
as mars developed they wanted to become
independent and were able to achieve
that when a martian named solomon
epstein invented a new type of fusion
drive this is what made it possible to
colonize the belt in the planetary
systems beyond the inner planets and
earth agreed to grant mars independence
in exchange for access to this
technology the democratic mars
congressional republic was formed and
became the second superpower and soul
system their population is only a
fraction of earth so they focused on
military strength and tech to even the
scales they prided themselves on their
ability to do more with less and
fostered a culture of extreme efficiency
this is the mars that characters like
alex kamal bobby draper and winston
duarte were born into they saw
themselves as the descendants of the
best and brightest from earth who
relocated to a dead rock with the
intention to turn it into a paradise
they saw this as the greatest
engineering project in human history and
nearly every person on mars was involved
with it in one way or another each
passing generation grew more accustomed
to living under domes and lost some of
the enthusiasm of their predecessors but
the project was still what held their
culture together and it was the thing
that defined the dream of mars things
started to fall apart when the ring
gates open with nearly 1400 new systems
to explore most of which having planets
with breathable atmospheres the
terraforming project no longer made
sense why work towards a project that
won't be completed in your lifetime when
you can go somewhere new and get started
right now in the same way the belters
looked at the future and saw they
weren't in it martians looked at it and
saw that their dream was dead this led
to a significant portion of the martian
population leaving mars and left career
military men and women with an uncertain
future winston duarte saw the writing on
the wall and an opportunity in this he
was able to get a lot of those military
people to buy into a new and improved
martian dream on a brand new planet
where they could start from scratch as i
mentioned before when alex met duarte he
was no one special just a career officer
in the navy what you'll learn later is
that at university he displayed a kind
of genius for logistics and in his
thesis he laid out a viable path for
mars to take control of the solar system
without firing a shot none of his
superiors took notice so he just settled
into doing his job for decades that
allowed him access to data from the
early probes that went through the gates
right after they opened and that's when
he noticed laconia's orbital platforms
those fit right into mars philosophy of
having a technological edge to overcome
the sheer size of earth's navy with that
information he shifted to organizing an
amazing theft that would put him in
control of a third of the martian navy's
ships while he armed the most radical
factions of the opa to create a
diversion he knew from the beginning
that the ringgate's opening would change
everything and believed that the path to
power would involve utilizing the
proto-molecule and its creator's
technology he believed if he didn't do
it someone else would and knew that he
wouldn't be able to break away and put
his plan in motion if earth and mars
navies weren't completely distracted he
worked with his conspirators to cover up
the findings about laconia they kept
that information from the rest of the
martian government and military banking
on the idea that having exclusive access
to this particular gate builder tech
would allow them to leave the other
powers behind they armed the free navy
and when marco threw his rocks at earth
that ensured that they would have to
spend generations on a recovery working
just to get themselves back to the place
they were in before the attacks that
would provide time for the new laconian
society to build themselves up that's
where they are at the end of season six
they made it to laconia with enough
ships and personnel to get themselves
started bringing the protomolecule
sample work to reactivate the gate
builder tech as seen with the orbital
platforms turning back on in the strange
dogs coming out of the woods to
reanimate zan after he died and having
cortazar there will help them understand
how to use it to realize their goals we
saw that when he told duarte that he had
received a coherent reply pattern so
what are these crazy ex-martians trying
to do duarte's early success is directly
related to the unique conditions
martians found themselves in after the
gold rush started for everyone to head
through the gates and stake their claim
people were worried about the future and
he had a plan with the orbital platforms
turned on and the inner planets occupied
with pressing problems closer to home
things are falling into place when they
announced the closing of the laconia
ring you see that his background and
logistics paid off since that's an
indication that they're in a position to
be self-sufficient cutting off trade
even with the belt in other colonies
beyond the rings means they have
everything they need to get started
the big plan they have is presented as a
mystery you don't really put all the
pieces together until about the eighth
book but the show did adapt two of the
scenes that are important as far as
planting seeds for the reveal that'll
come later in season five there's a
conversation between soviet era and
babbage about her breaking the dress
code by wearing a bracelet with her
uniform he makes the point that what
they're doing changes things and that on
laconia there won't be a civilian world
to cushion them if they fall
dishonorable discharge will be a bullet
or worse and you hear some of this in
the final season when the lakonians are
talking about the driver getting the
firing squad even though zan's death was
an accident on the bar keith babbage
says we have to be more pure now than
mars ever was one mind one cause and
that's pretty much it in a nutshell the
laconians believe that the martian
government failed its people when the
ring gates opened and they believe that
the problem can be solved by a military
government built on discipline and
dedication to the cause everyone working
towards a common goal in the same way
that martians work together trying to
turn their planet into a paradise duarte
understands the importance of a strong
leader in that structure and in season 6
you hear that in his conversation with
kara at zan's wake he reinforces the
idea that the opening of the ring gates
killed the dream of mars in relation to
the terraforming project he says that he
wants to make that a sacrifice so that
that dream still matters and he says
when those rings open we all ran out
into the universe like your brother ran
out into that road no one could stop us
so instead someone has to keep us safe
or at least try he sees himself as that
person the fact that somebody else was
gonna do this if he didn't was a big
part of his motivation in getting this
in motion in the first place now that
he's been able to pull that off and they
have a nice new planet with some tech
that the rest of humanity doesn't have
access to you can see why people would
follow him or at least you could see why
these specific people would follow him
and if you want to see how that turns
out i suppose you need to read the final
trilogy in the book series he's an
interesting leader that emerges in a
period of this imagined future where it
makes sense he wasn't wrong in thinking
that things would never be the same
after the ring gates opened or that
someone else would try to use the
protomolecule if they didn't he believes
that a strict military dictatorship is
the best form of government because he
believes he could be the right
benevolent ruler to guide it some of his
points are sound on their own a society
working together for a common goal the
end of tribalism the end of the factions
that divided humanity and soul system
plus you can't really argue with the
potential of the proto-molecule by the
end of season six advancements are
happening that weren't possible before
it was discovered this might lead to
earth's food crisis being solved through
prax's research and so he's not crazy to
think that using it will give him the
technological advantage his much smaller
military would need the show did a great
job of conveying his strange charisma as
well he comes off as really having
things figured out and competent enough
to fix history it doesn't change the
fact that he's a bad guy but it does
probably mean that some teenager
somewhere will write a post or an essay
on why duarte was right actually what
i've talked about so far is just the
introduction and things do get pretty
interesting there's one other thing that
drives him and he hints at it in his
conversation with kara when he says
someone has to keep us safe and makes it
more explicit talking to marco when he
says he has gods to kill duarte
understands that the civilization that
created the protomolecule was far more
advanced than humanity and that another
civilization came along and wiped them
out of existence he believes that the
unknown aggressors will eventually pose
a threat to humans and that knowing that
means that he would be responsible for
neutralizing it if he's going to be the
leader and i think that's a good place
to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought about this
character in the tv show and if you want
to talk about the books just make sure
you mark those spoilers so they won't
ruin it for people who haven't read
ahead please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon